yeah there's actually a couple of things  going on on the area of i-15 and blue  diamond first of all your overall  freeways are in excellent shape as  you're getting up and at them here  on your thursday morning just after five  o'clock but this situation has been  happening since  10 30 yesterday morning some kind of a  barricade or standoff you cannot get off  a blue diamond to go on to dean martin  there's also a crash this is southbound  on the 15 just before  blue diamond we will start with the  police activity you can see the flashing  lights here blocking off dean martin  now for the south on 15 before blue  diamond looks like it's all on the left  shoulder maybe somebody off on the right  shoulder the good news the freeway  through lanes are moving along in pretty  good shape alex